[Music]
so elder skeet this next person would
like us to explain the difference
between mind
excusing between body mind spirit and
soul
okay
well there's even more but i'll just
pause right there yeah well
the soul can the soul freaking refers to
just a person
the soul can also mean all your
emotional makeup your attitude if you
read a numbers 21
verse 4
and they took the journey from andhra by
the way of the red sea i think to
compass the land of edon and the soul of
the people was much discouraged by the
way
they were tired they pressed discouraged
emotionally the trip took their toll and
so the soul of the people it means not
your emotional structure it is you know
you this journey is taking too much out
of me
but man became a living soul soul is
frequently a living being
when god sends the plagues in revelation
16 every soul in the sea die means the
fish so a living being is a soul you
have to study contextually the mind
that's the intellectual capacity you see
where we make decisions that's in here
and the soul can sometimes be the
spiritual part of a person we have to
study contextually so mind but all of
this makes up just one person a person
has a mind a person has an emotional
structure a person has you know a
capacity to be spiritual but we don't
have three different people when a
person dies the mind doesn't go north
the soul south and whatever east it's
one person who has components to that
person
you know the heart has four chambers but
it's one height
and all chambers don't do exactly the
same thing
the upper does something different from
the lower but i'm not a doctor dr
mccarthy and so don't accuse me of
malpractice all right next question
all right next question let me
and there's a verse that says don't
recall where the spirit of man is the
candle of the lord in other words your
attitude how do you behave do you rush
off do you fly off the handle how do you
handle the spirit of man is the candle
of the lord god's character can shine
through you just by your attitude the
spirit of man is the camel of the lord
your spirit some people say he has a
depressing spirit he has a joyful spirit
it doesn't mean there's a ghost living
in you it's just the way you conduct
yourself holy spirit
all right
all right thank you elder
you